okay for people joining this livestream
this is one in a series of meetings
talking about synthetic geometry a
molten language and let's take a look at
what we've got here so what we want to
do here is represent this image in this
question in our language so see if we
can understand this so we have a
geometric scene with a bunch of
variables here that represents the
points represent the points in the star
so it's ABCD I don't know where and we
have to label it but in order to get
this counterclockwise angle what does
that mean
why isn't what what is an angle what why
do we have to say counterclockwise angle
oh because there's two does the angle on
the outside as well right if you just
put an angle it seems it's the angle
between 0 and 180 but if you want to
guarantee the the shape you see above
you have to specify the orientation well
what does counterclockwise when you have
BCE that means that the angle BCE at the
vertex C if you if you sweep
counterclockwise 100 degrees you'll get
you will go from the line segment Cee to
the line segment CD or like we got like
from the line segment BC to the line
segment Cee okay let's take a look at
all of these so these are all the things
that you are trying to introduce here is
that correct yeah they include a few
extra things just for to help with
debugging
okay so there is an ocean angle right
and I don't understand why this isn't
some option to angle or something cuz
this seems very obscure yeah I mean in
other words well let's let's take a look
at what you okay so then the aluminous
yeah ja the same okay why aren't those
labels in some way with power there
drill caps I think it should have a
label shouldn't it why not
sometimes we've been but something weird
about glider Roger - can you comment on
this little from experience with graphs
and so on I yeah I think you're gonna
have to I think it's gonna be work to
manage label placement I think it should
be done but I think you have to have
kind of this overall objective being
able so where did we where do we decide
that the nodes should be in this I mean
because the nodes if this angle was a
named angle what would it look like if
you so currently angle refers to just
angle measure so if you you can't really
name an angle okay so let's imagine that
that I just didn't do what you told me
to do there and I get rid of
counterclockwise okay
and then I say okay so that time it
worked just fine right am i saying
saying if I make a table of multiple
instances of this that sometime it might
flop around in some weird you can you
don't need to do table yeah you can just
do Garrett of table and just happened
that what just happened
these are really small you have to
expand them so what you'll want to do if
why did it do that why did it do that
what
got really small that's wrong right well
so if you do find your metric seen in
wait a second wait wait I don't care
about that I work why did it go wrong
when it goes small probably something do
with absolute versus relative sizes of
judgments okay so it's wrong right now
so those are wrong right yeah fixed
right makes sense yeah okay so what's
your point here we were looking
hunky-dory well they're differently
configured I see so see here right oh no
no these are fine what's wrong with this
I think seems to be wrong in this
instance yes well we've got five
instances here all right and so far
nothing is wrong but you're saying there
is a solution you believe ah look at
that fifth time lucky
what's that something's gone very very
wrong here right well I complicated
enough scenes every once in a while that
will be a degenerate case hold on hold
on what does this mean what what just
happened here so the way the I don't get
this I don't get how this managed to get
so the angles here this is what is the
angle around a hey whoever's making
background noise could you not do that a
JB is 40 degrees what okay so where's H
it's as collapsed collapse then their
air or one of the other points how could
it be collapsed under hey so see how do
we know I mean this kind of degeneracy
right is obviously if points are on top
of each other it's an it's not an
adequate solution correct
so do we not test for the
it's kind of impossible to test for that
without eliminating some user you know
the user specifies that you know points
are supposed to be very close to : E or
something
then it's kind of hard to test so look
up whether the user specified that and
if the user didn't give any such
condition then worry if the things are
degenerate like this you look worst case
you just try another random seed right
right are you rejecting this and how
many random seeds you typically trying
to get the solutions you do get depends
on the depends on the complexity one are
we talking 10,000 closer to 1 than
10,000 we the max iteration limit is I
think said it 150 now and you know every
once in a while it'll here's a question
could we figure out if we've got three
of these three different instances yeah
and we ask the question do they look
similar okay if we could answer that
question then we could reject this one
I'm making sense yes but they were
similar you mean in there not in a
technical sense not in any kind of
technical sense I mean visually and I
have no idea whether this is doable
visually do these pictures look I mean I
have no idea whether we can do that I
mean that's a kind of machine learning
adventure well I mean the way we would
do it is we would see which points all
we really care about our which points
are far our you know non-trivial
distance apart from each other because
you know the way to set up is if ya okay
so the distance matrix of those points
you're asking all the zeroes in that
disel Coast zeroes and that distance
mate right but we might also need to
check collinear T because sometimes
you know check check that that points
are not you're really far apart and if
they're you know putative Li not
supposed to know any more they're not so
fine so that's a possible thing to do so
because I think we need to avoid that
kind of degenerate case yes sir okay and
also something's wrong with the sizing
thing you'll deal with that okay all
right now let's talk about this angle
thing um right
so they have clockwise and
counterclockwise and or and I'm not sure
why you don't just have an angle and a
directed I mean if you look at the
literature right there are two concepts
of angle right there's the here's here -
here's an unordered pair of line
segments that need an appoint and you
know here's an incoming line segment and
then you rotate from that so why do we
need a clockwise and counterclockwise as
opposed to just well there's quite a bit
of more material related to English all
right yeah so we're just at the top
we're just kind of sharing you the work
flow honestly the majority of this
notebook at the end is the discussion of
angles okay fine I mean I would just
like to make the possible suggestion
that that might be a way of dealing with
a directed angle it was important to
differentiate between an angle an angle
measure all right okay fine let's let's
go further down in this notebook okay so
let's look keep looking at this work
flow okay so let's take a look at this
this is a geometric scene with actual
instances for the coordinates of the
port so this is the input form of the
scene you you through previous what are
we using hold form here I don't
understand this well there's some
there's some auto auto evaluation
problems with also so like infinite line
will auto evaluate if it's included a
list of yeah so we need to fix that
because that clearly we're not going to
have a hold full right the hold
is-is-is just for for us now okay so how
are we fixing those things is it is the
infinite line evaluation because was
something that's done for some other
purpose or is it how is that gonna be
fixed I believe I can let Charles and
eat I probably speak for this but I
believe that they're planning on ending
the auto evaluation of infinite line
where if you have infinite line of lists
a comma B yeah they're on this on the
subject this who is this Charles who
should be here
is Roger here yes but I don't know why
it's Otto evaluating now normally we do
it to canonicalize to get rid of cases
and that's usually an important thing in
sort of implementation cost so yeah so
can I'm not sure what can somebody find
Charles if Charles is not here or is
Charles here
Charles is off today actually chosen CEO
today okay so who knows the answer to
this question do I have to go research
it myself I mean you can't say that it
isn't clear how to get documents or
valuation of any kind no I mean like
it's not supposed okay the whole system
is built like that Stephen I mean you
you I mean what special functions ought
to evaluate that's been killing us for
endless years okay fine but you don't
think this is supposed to be also
evaluating I mean normally a sort of a
we have things that ought to evaluate
they supposed to do that that's a okay
fine so you guys in it's usually a whole
architecture behind it everything has to
be aware of it right everybody needs to
wear a bit the cost goes way up
okay bottom line here is that shouldn't
be a whole form there and Peter and so
on you need to figure out what needs to
be done to make sure you don't have to
have that right I think there are two
possibilities like if the holes most of
our functions eval a they'd they do some
non-trivial computations
Yama's the concerns this representation
so the worlds have some friction bit so
let's find out what the issues are
potentially one had we have to use in
inactive to to the percent whenever
peter has said there's an issue with
infinite line but he can't tell us what
it is so and i to justify having this so
so i mean it's not stupid steven what's
done
I mean it's so I don't know so it's
probably and and the question is why
does it even matter to hope but because
the canonicalization you're doing I'm
surprised that that meshes badly with
the synthetic geometry stuff and I'm
suspicious that it doesn't well so they
right that's also a problem so like for
instance our twink will get mad if you
don't okay you know what you guys have
to sort this out okay because that's
probably an error message for our
clients that it probably doesn't need to
have right this that's not unusual that
we have to look at that I know I know
as we as we turn it into the meaning
something symbolically absolutely so
okay okay let's make a matter point here
you know this is coordination between
multiple groups we don't have a project
manager for this we probably should have
a project manager for this if we're
going to have to coordinate between
these several groups or duo does Peter
think I doesn't seem like Peter is
handling this so I think we should I
think that Charles is sitting in on
regular of these meetings yes we have
monthly meetings to coordinate okay but
so we somebody organized this meeting
one but Charles wasn't here which was a
mistake so let's make sure we don't have
any more of these without Charles in
them fair supposedly coordinating
between these these efforts today
indicate the issue with infinite radness
the following there's a one argument
formed as a list which assumes that the
other point is zero zero so if you
evaluate infinite line of I guess it I
understand infinite line
a one argument form with a b-line then
you got that okay what do you want in
front line to mean imitation is that
infinite the end of this p1 p2
representative straight line from p1 p2
but the question is here is a now a
point or is a accordionist
yeah I mean this is the basic problem we
have with symbolic variables they are
assumed to be scalar complex numbers and
here you want the night it to be scalar
northerly point yep we've been fighting
that everywhere that hardwired types
yeah well looks like Charles just joined
oh okay good yes Christmas like should
this happen yes can we have a problem
let's let Charles answer why he thinks
that should happen it isn't even
documented well that's I mean when he
see it not documented that divided
attempts even that was actually one of
our quest several of the constructor or
to evaluate to some sample case it was
your request especially when you want to
do essentially computation politic you
need to actually assume that those are
no fixed value you simplify them to
automatically save into a sample form
and this is actually one problem Michael
we discuss right I mean that's the main
issue do synthetic geometry yes yeah
well so I'm probably wrong I mean
there's a there's an overarching reason
why we shouldn't do this one argument
form like this
I mean this is also what we get in
synthetic geometry for not decorating
the ABCD here right I mean this is you
know the other way of doing this is to
decorate those you know variables and
not have them be naked symbols right
would this help because then we could
easily make infant line on a decorated
you know point a point B or something
geometric point a geometric point B
doesn't have to evaluate like this yes
okay but of course the energy gets much
rub elbows everything I understand so
you know right
okay so let's inventory what cases there
are of Auto evaluation that causes
trouble with geometric scene okay are
there lots are there like three of them
so bi besides there's infinite line half
line that's the same thing okay and then
reading things like if you do area of a
where a is not an explicit region that
just gives an arrow
okay that's fine so that error doesn't
need to happen right so basically I'm
the only auto evaluation problems are
instant line and half well so that was a
that was a case apparently added in
response to a comment of mine not
documented and not necessarily necessary
so if that's really if that's a little
tiny thread on which this whole issue
hangs I think we can fix that makes
sense let's make sure that there aren't
other ones looking there are more
serious right so this is the only reason
and that's you know we should get rid of
depend of what you mean by tiny amino to
evaluation we have if you do circle with
no argument we took value to zero zero I
doubt that's problematic here now that
that is actually for that I can do it
but let's inventory what auto evaluation
there is for these things and whether it
does or does not cause trouble for the
patek geometry stuff and let's find out
you know whether this is a tiny thread
or whether this is a giant piece of rope
well it's Oh Stephen I agree with all
that but I just want to make the account
from at a point which is that we do have
cases where if we have a a wrapper
that's not hold something that we
wrapped things unfold inside of that to
carry around metadata so I'm Stephen in
this case we actually already discussed
that on we actually came to a conclusion
we decided to watch you know which
method we should remove and why we
should hold on a valuation Michael I
believe we did that a while ago yeah
with it so wait that's not a problem
really I'm sorry I'm sorry what are you
saying I think we solve this problem
already we discussed it already with
choice so in it so this problem has gone
away or this problem is still where you
will be six excellent good happy ending
okay let's move on okay find geometric
conjectures so so if you evaluate this
it'll on top return the scene but the
input form has an additional argument
which is you're not seriously proposing
this as being the way that you get this
out I didn't like you don't want to get
the scene is baffling yes right so yeah
I would think the solution would be the
same would be you you have the input
form be the way we have it but instead
of formatting add oh no no I don't agree
look if it's cold find geometric
conjectures return the conjectures don't
return the scene why are you returning
the scene well no I mean I mean they're
the the I think the input form
I like as is but instead I need to
return the scene you asked for the
conjectures why isn't it just returning
a list of the conjectures because then
it kinda makes many things naked without
context and meaning okay but this is a
geometric scene and you're annotating
you having what a third argument in the
scene that is the conjectures yes it's
pretty weird I mean I would argue that
you know definitely instead of showing
just drawing the picture again on the
top level it should be seriously that's
ridiculous right yes no question okay
right so why not just have a geometric
conjectures which maybe it had the right
D arguments are the same you just
changed ahead and we can do whatever the
hell we want with the typesetting no but
also a whole thing that the issue is
what are you going to do with those
conjectures from here you're probably
going to extract them and start doing
things with them but you've now got
these would you wisdom do you expect to
victory you visualize the conjectures
just as you visualize the scene yes
exactly
I don't know I have that formatting
things original code did it visualize
all of the connection that's why I was
in the so though we could attach the
formatting okay so something is broken
yes there's something okay but so are we
also going to have extractors for the
geometric for this thing whatever this
is you know sub quotes conjectures or
something to extract just the
conjectures so you're not doing this
weird input form yes yes yeah okay okay
think it should be a different head you
know probably yes
I'm not sure though they didn't Kenda
what else have you thought about what
what do you have you guys thought about
what you want the conjectures for what
are you gonna do with them next only
this thing is proving them okay so prove
them you talked about visualizing them
proving them you know and admire them in
some way but but in particular you
probably want to want to pick out eight
but check the other conjecture that you
want to prove visualize or whatever but
yeah so previously this find geometric
proof you take this extracted thing and
then you give it the original scene not
the conjectures which why not
it takes the conjecture and you give it
an index or something or if we wrap them
all up into this big thing why not do
that well I know son find geometric
proof I mean first question is is some
given result actually true yeah you you
can ask that by putting in a pattern
without any blanks okay but how would I
do that but I also can find your
electric proof you want more EQ funked
that's what I'm saying I'm asking the
question can I tell you know ah blah
blah blah and blah : eeeh so it's so far
we can just return a proof of that or if
there is no proof then - but I mean is
it faster for you to tell whether it's
true than to generate a proof no not to
tell what the heck is that
no I don't know the first I the first
error is very strange it means you have
a mismatch between the template message
template and the arguments you're
feeding it so that's some bug in your
code yeah I actually just started
getting that today and I was confused
about them
oh yeah I don't think I don't know um so
what that means so that this now what
was a proof that has 51 steps and
doesn't find okay
okay but this says equation or logic so
what why would the proof network not to
come out was it called proof graph or
something yes there's a below you can
look below where I do that and it's yeah
I shouldn't have let you do that if you
just looked below there's a the proof
graph and it's called proof graph 2
because it doesn't work right now it
hasn't been reported I'm getting it into
the framework of fide the creation of
proof that's not yet ready okay and so
these are the lemmas is that right yeah
the ones with the red arrows going to
them are they Givens and then dilemmas
are everything else and the last one is
the thing that we asked for so so these
are constructed lemmas that the system
came up with is my correct yes
okay that's the comprehensible or not
that's mirrored exactly by the two
column proof above I wish you could
click the facts to happen you can't okay
fair enough so when you do this in
practice so those lemmas end up being
comprehensible things are they something
totally weird and computer istic know
they're they're comprehensible that was
I've engineered them to be as
comprehensive as possible and I have
these these nice forms for them as you
see the two column proof but I could use
some help and some work making those
maybe a little better are you sure no
it's an image yeah those periods that
the decimal points should be suppressed
somehow okay I think that's an issue in
probably in angle formatting that's a
quantity formatting issue I think
but but this poof thing is just right
now to show kinda how the work flow
continues there is not quite okay so
don't convict so we could have a head
giametta connectors and if you are in
the conjecture mode we show connectors
and then connect rows of seen could make
an actress and seen of connectors could
discard connectors maybe do so on a
little bit unconvinced what we're gonna
do with these conjectures but the
problem is what happens when you take a
conjecture out and it has naked you know
symbols representing points right and
you know from some point of view you
could say well oh my gosh you know it's
so scary to have a polynomial with naked
X's and Y's representing you know things
so and you know just don't worry about
it
just say okay you take it out if you've
already given F some weird value you're
gonna get a stupid answer but that's a
different issue you put F in you can
bring in audio problems because nothing
is healthier
no I understand I understand right so
your point is my point is just like you
could be scared of a naked polynomial
you could be similarly scared of a naked
geometric conjecture just let them come
out am I making sense yep
and that way sorry to say that yeah if
geometric scene is not hold anything so
it's protecting the them somehow
then you know we just hang out and and I
would argue I mean there is a slight
scoping issue and I don't fully
understand that but I would argue that
fine geometric conjectures should just
literally give this as a list without
any other tentacles
you know without anything else in other
words you could make the same argument
for a polynomial oh my gosh I don't know
what X&Y mean you know after you take we
do some operation on a polynomial or a
boolean function or anything else that
has variables but then if you want to
nicely visualize this you'd need a
function that takes two arguments to
connect rows and the scene which is a
little bit is that really such a stupid
idea I mean you want what's that it's a
little bit unusual when do we when do we
generate two things and then unite them
again if there really are most useful
United then we can keep them United for
every time we call Maps thread okay
let's keep going
meeting assault indicate like function
where you never care the split well
eigen system
keeps it together well that one does but
eigen values and eigen eigen vectors
does not typically be all at the end
then you have an eigen system what
operation to you apply to the values and
the vectors together to make something
you typically nothing but here the
visualization is very common operation
very neat pose yeah I understand 82
movies : right okay but let's try let's
keep going here um okay this skip over
that stiff to the next section
okay all right so so I'm just trying to
understand here so this yeah I get this
this is a pretty nice pretty interesting
um okay let's keep going so these are
just kind of examples of scenes you can
draw and some functionality and it would
start to voltage novel right so style
works but it's ignored so to speak no no
no so this is right so run this right so
you made the third lines in points red
okay you can do it we also added
geometry decided nice I mean this is
quite impressive actually
okay so hold on a second so this is now
I see so here you're using strings
because you can use anything yeah Amy is
anything I think this is what we should
use in the documentation I kind of agree
with you yeah it's definitely safer so
one accidentally in terms of the
evaluation issue
I mean clearly the infinite line thing
certainly wouldn't evaluate with strings
but well whatever it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter but but with that that
problem is being solved separately what
does this mean mean infinite line list a
B what does that mean
so this means that it's an infinite line
that just goes through the point a B it
doesn't say any other points I said why
does it have a list in it
see you guys infinite line takes a list
of points that it goes through so the
now but that's the thing that we're
hopefully changing right to allow this
infinite line wouldn't want expect that
infinite line have a single thing that
would mean the obvious thing no there is
a point called a B that's going through
right so if you do infinite line of
lists a comma
versi string a comma string the comma
string C it will be an infinite line
that goes through those points ABC in
order fair enough fair enough okay and
presumably the I mean many times these
diagrams and so on will be generated by
some kind of drawing tool that has an
infinite line construct that you can
simply put in it's that true we are
making some first steps in this
direction yes okay all right but you
should stay a moment mr. genetic poverty
we discussed the last time defeating you
didn't fully sign up on it I didn't
notice it here okay hold on so this is a
whole boatload of different random
properties is that correct correct we
also use it lower for perpendicular so
this is an alternative to saying okay so
there's equality which is and we have
certain things like collinearity is that
correct which is own separate broken out
function and then we have the kind of
vast collection of other geometric
properties like is this I don't know is
this on the circumcircle of a triangle
or something weird like that which we
are doing with this geometric property
thing is that the idea yeah I think I
can go in here is a geometric property
okay well good the closing is having
we can hear you in basically instead of
having a ton of symbols that I think the
region group would feel kind of
obligated to support right away we're at
least starting with this geometric
property head that's clear that it's
really only applies to inside these
geometric seams and then how do we like
my name geometric property or is that
going to cause us yet another property
disaster so to speak Roger and Charles
no I mean it's called geometric property
it's fine no no no but the property
thing that you have for graphs which I
hate so much is this compatible with
that usage or not no it's not okay
and nor is it compatible with the entity
property notion so I would even say
that's a totally different notion it is
a totally different notion but it has
the word property and yes and I'm just
trying to I'm just trying to find a
different name here for this it's
geometric vitro
I was thinking feature but that seems
awfully weird and I was like sounds like
feature extraction um I mean it's a
geometric truth in some sense it's a
geometric solution
what's that geometric assertion and
that's that's you know actually closer
to the way it's using because we're
asserting this to be true in this
picture you got yeah that's that's not
bad is it a session or a cert I think it
did not search in okay fine well it's
that's definitely better than geometric
property so fine I like it because it
also extends language wise a little bit
better to the Moody argument case are
you talking about multi argument of the
second argument or the first argument
even scroll down I share the multi
argument version of the first one that's
a little confusing in this case let's go
back well okay right right so if you
want to do this all at once you can do
lists of infinite line or I see a list
of those lines all being perpendicular
yeah so okay so let's take a look at
this again for a second so you're saying
geometric assertion that those things
perpendicular that's pretty reasonable I
think I think that it's much better I
like it much further okay
and why is this midpoint not also
geometric assertion because you actually
want the midpoint out as a thing so you
might as well do it this way the
midpoint is actually an unidentified
object whereas this thing here is a mere
predicate so to speak yeah fine
so equality is the only predicate that
is sort of broken out outside of
geometric assertion that correct end
element okay fine okay that makes sense
so those are the two things that are
assertions but are not in the kind of
big bucket of geometric assertion yes
believe so yes
Michael Hale livestream is asking the
question whether the word whether it
should be geometric constraint rather
than geometric assertion it's you know
people are certainly going to start
worrying about follow me and such things
when you talk about constraints well it
also might not be satisfiable right well
what do you guys think I mean Michael
what is you what do you think I have a
slight reference to assault it sounds a
little bit friendlier and more input you
know although as developer on the the
fine geometric scene instance geometric
constraint is actually very similar to
how we treat these inputs so it is like
from from the narrative point of view
you ever seen in the case of image in
point of view from some textbook and you
assert that this is the case you don't
think there's the infinite space out and
now I put constraints after constraints
on it's it's equivalent viewpoint but I
don't think
okay also on our livestream Ron Anderson
is asking if this will be available for
spherical geometry and and I think
that's a looking gift horse in the mouth
type situation this is their this is
hard enough to do for further plane
geometry case and we're proud of being
able to get close to being able to do it
um
let's cross this bridge first okay so
let's take a look so one thing I write
okay so just one note is that this multi
argument form of G
well geometric property slash geometric
assertion slash geometric constraint it
does not match it's very close to
matching how style works but does not
exactly match the style does not allow
the multiply argument form in for the
first argument is that something we
should allow at least in geometric
property for instance if you want to
make a bunch of things red currently you
have to do a bunch of commands rather
than one command will you uh solve those
things and say that right I I think you
might as well let style sort of be list
commuting if you understand what I'm
saying so you're saying support that I
think so I mean by list commuting I mean
that style of a list is equivalent to a
list of style
all right that's that's how I treat the
geometric properties stuff it's just
it's not document for style I don't
think
and the related question we had we
discussed this sometimes you want to
style the property not every property is
dilated but say if two lines are
perpendicular you might want the little
dot with a quarter circle to beef do we
scrape the stylus I think probably
around the property name around the
assertion name I think it's a little bit
odd yeah it's a little odd yeah just
making sure that everybody it's a little
odd but I think it's the reasonable
thing to do I think it's
Istanbul yeah so there's a simpler
example and a boring how did you manage
to why is this gray inside oma polygon
but that polygon isn't saying anything
right to it so we decided to make a
grace of you do so if you put style
comma red we don't want the user to have
to change the opacity I can hardly see
it's light green right there paucity if
you you've preset an opacity ya the
opacity is currently point one it was
point zero if you want to change the
opacity you can put it in the style
thing but the idea is if the user puts
in red they're gonna get frustrated if
they don't realize that oh the attacks
would be set to zero I need to change
the opacity it's individually dubis a
countries in Geographics i think it's
the right thing I think opacity is
orthogonal to color to the human I think
we got a caller qualities fair enough so
there's default opacity butBut I
understand saying polygons there it's
very different from I mean polygons it's
just like okay probably gone great
that's nice but so what type figure I'd
suggest same enjoy I see so in other
words if I were to put here circle
quotes a so you mean cool right so also
polygons actually does have a built in
assertion that the polygon is simple
inside geometric scene right inside your
context is not supported so Roger and
Charles I mean is that correct going
forward so to speak no not at all
polygon doesn't do it's fine geometric
seen instance makes assumptions about
points that are inside a polygon but is
that the I mean the polygon that is
going for
that is going to include holy polygons
and things like audience who wants to
use this tool they don't want a moody
connect at all
whatever poverty polygon that's not the
understanding of a polygon in element of
it I understand but if we are going to
make our polygon directive support weird
multi polygon things then that's a bit
inconsistent here I mean it already
supports multi polygon it's about
polygons life is rich Steven so if there
is a our polygon can render a bowtie
correct
great but this polygon will prevent
bowties is that correct correct I think
you guys are just treating it as a as an
unsaid assumption and documentation it
will be said ok bye ok fine but so if
you wanted a polygon that could be a
bowtie you're out of luck for right now
correct I could you know in the code I
could say if all of the all of the point
inputs are concrete then to just draw it
without any assumption in which case you
get a bowtie but currently you would
have to draw a bunch of line segments to
look like the polygon oh yeah I
understand
so the polygon itself has an implicit
assumption of being simple ok yeah ok
that's probably ok so then this is just
another way of saying the same thing
with geometric property again say
examine I click mean means that the
vertices all I intercept they're all
[Music]
really weird yeah I thought that meant
you know like a permutation I thought
cyclic meant in a cycle no that is a
crazy name for this that is not common
yeah so another meaning of sick
talk about cyclic polygons okay we need
a different name for that that doesn't
confuse me and Roger who are admittedly
we're not necessarily the center of the
market for this but we shouldn't be
confused if we avoid confusing you then
we will guaranteed confuse all high
school students using this but it is
thing it does not do any harm no but
isn't that we said you know cos I click
on Congo cyclic yeah it's a Charles
Charles suggested can't say quack which
you say that a group of points is
concealing you say that a polygon is
cyclic yeah
Khan cyclic means for a group of points
look we got to do something about this
this is not a supportable thing it's too
weird what would be the way of okay when
so you would say geometric assertion of
a a b c d list a b c d comecon cyclic is
that what it is right now
I don't think consequence you could just
do circle through of ABCD well why
doesn't this just say so go through in
the polygon case as well so there is a
much much much much better name than
constantly well circle so circle through
will consider if you circle through you
have to do circle through the points and
then if you're also on the polygon you
have to do polygon to the point so the
geometric property of polygon comma
cyclic just eliminates one of the
arguments I'm sorry what do you mean
polygon no no so circle through is the
constructor it's not a oh I Souter
saying okay if you want to if you would
also combine that somehow into this
well maybe we did a name here because
circle through is a nice clear you know
I mean really what this is is has a
circle through these right well so we
could do use circle through I would like
to keep it as the constructor but we
could know
it's a fine thing for the constructor
right we could also use the best deal
what about points on circles or vertices
on circles that's so obviously correct
for what it's worth we use cyclic
polygons on math world go what so what
ethanol doesn't know what an in spear is
so you know I don't think vertices on
circle is beautiful either but something
we got to do something about the cyclic
thing and okay we're of course running
out of time here but let's take a little
look through some more of this um let's
talk also about speed is that is the
speed we're seeing here what we can
expect to see or is this um the simpler
the the same usually the better it is if
you specify a bunch of angles then it
that slows it down I improve the speed
on especially like regular polygons and
stuff which we'll see in but to miss
their next by the way another question
do we have a plan for a repository of
knowing theorems since really we can put
we we have a set of known theorems for
test so we could make it a percent of
the other I think it'd be nice because I
mean clearly a bunch of these are very
well defined you know we now have a
well-defined whatever representing them
I mean in particular the theorems so how
would we represent the theorem we
represent it as a geometric scene is
that correct
with the conjecture argument so then why
are we calling them conjectures when
when the things that come out and are
known to be true yeah we discussed
having baby some more structure indicate
the actual argument to differentiate
between bonds and Waconia trois what was
there or conjecture what do you mean by
raw conjecture well they each one of
eight but we don't know if it's true
right we generate based only on the
coordinates returned by the fine team
instance whereas the the theorems are
are returned by the the prover and has a
have an accompanying truth okay well I
don't understand I mean I understand
that distinction is you're describing it
I don't think the design is right in
terms of I think that's a that's crazy I
mean you know the theorems are lovely
nuggets the conjectures are you know
they might be a diamond or they might be
a fake one or something except that here
we're saying that they're all in the
same bucket no Faraday did the bucket is
divided potentially think the thing it
would be interesting to have a sort of a
curated collections of these you know
statements should should one also
provide proof in those or should one
just have the statement you know they
know it's true and there you can run the
system to generate a proof or any nice
to have the proofs as well yeah we
should we should have a proof
verification object like they do for
equation of logic yes I'm working on
that but that's a lot cheaper right but
I mean how many just to give me a sense
how many theorems can we expect to have
in the inner in a theorem repository for
this low few hundreds that's not very
nice how many are like in math world for
example comparable number didn't be not
a seventy but I'm not sure I see okay
how many named theorems out there this
type I can't imagine that many more than
hundreds I was thinking low hundreds
okay if I wanted to say that this was
not regular or something is there any
way to do that - no not currently the
is yeah curtain Oh currently you cannot
you can do not actually know say
mediations but then also then scrapping
in note around we would make a new
string not regular well so you could
yeah
the you one of the the problems which I
could work around is you know internally
this uses fine minimum okay with IVA opt
and that the constraints pass to that
are kind of limited so like an
inequality that can't handle but if you
do a strictly less than or strictly
greater than you know that works so I
can probably translate into something
that that it could handle in certain
instances always um okay but in general
if you do a not statements and you try
to keep it general it will completely
slowed things down that in principle
okay so the geometric assertion thing in
principle there could be a boolean
combination of geometric assertions
logical combination of geometric
assertions you'd say this one and not
that one this one or that one
in principle I'm not saying we could do
that today but that in principle yes
what is this what is that three doing
there so that three says we're getting
three instances like is there an
advantage speed wise to doing it that
way there slight advantage in the see
translating the user input you can just
do that
once which really is doesn't matter this
is more for I think it supposed to fall
apart late to find the instance so I
mean then why are we doing the tabbing
find instance would give a list I mean
we should we should
as possible do things where we can
actually compute with the output okay so
but it still the geometric scene -
between computers that put this tab
thing is told geometric scene yes the
video input form on this is the
geometric same means we keep everything
in geometric see do you like that
Michael but it's some I like it because
I because of this first argument that
specifies the point I do not like making
spot of them naked candle taking their
context away that's why I like keeping
them all together why not a list of
geometric scenes as the output what is
the format or as the output no I'm
saying that the format would be a list
yes
no no I think ideally it should be
similar to manipulate and others where
we have an option that says how it's to
be formatted okay do you have a reason
why you think the tabbed thing is better
than simply a list of things that are
like all the elements no so you're not
particularly pushing the tabs well the
reason the reason we weren't with at
least in the display for the tab over
the list was so that we could keep this
as having a geometric scene head which
you okay as opposed to a list of
geometric scene right and so if you if
you had a list if you format it as a
listen do you make it seems people are
gonna think it's a list when in fact
it's not because it's just a single game
achievement list in a slightly general
sense like a fix-all or something like
this I know it wasn't what I meant I
meant no actual raw list then but then
we used a head if I understand
I actually like to tap you because it
you can see the entire screen because
you always need to blow them up and you
can just see them bigger this way and I
like to keep them together is if you
have something really complicated and
you want to derive Cognac shows
keeping them all together and using them
all for the connectors of course much
more efficient
this discussion of angles is going to be
a long discussion yeah simple things
which are most difficult I say it ain't
a heated one right there seems we
discussed the six weeks eternally and
it's still just a 1d angle but I didn't
trust the papers for the moody angles in
n dimensions or the dis generalization
is easy we just need general Moody all
type of geometrics what the heck the
hypergeometric have to do with it
actually already a simple forty anger
generically as a driver yard
hypergeometric when you buy is you mean
for what is it the metal for what is
michael action of the of the sphere yes
exactly
okay yes I believe that yep they become
I mentioned they become pretty
complicated analytically what are they
in 3d
elliptic mm-hmm okay so this is so
you're saying if you want to integrate
over a small part of the sphere of the
hyper sphere it's specified by a certain
angle what is the the surface what is
the measure of the slice the sphere go
it within that angle yes
I never okay so but that angle might be
is that like a cone is that the yes yes
what is the area of a cap on a sphere I
don't I should know that it's not
something obvious it's does it easy but
like if an angle in 2d is basically two
lines meaning the simple simply extend
the simplest version of Anglian sweetie
are see lines it's not a cap oh I have
no idea how you specify that you give it
all the lines and say spend their
surface in between so it's a try it it's
a spherical triangle yes yes okay oh I
see so the area of a spherical triangle
what is the area of a spherical triangle
just I mean it isn't it it's not it's
some not trigonometric it's elliptic I
don't know about no okay all right well
anyway look I think we should have a
separate I mean I mean but this is
pretty nice guys I mean this is really
pretty nice can we follow up fairly
quickly so we haven't lost context here
and we obviously need then leaves in a
couple of days right I'm going to
Portugal for a conference next week
talking about this yeah okay so let's
try and get this in like tomorrow ish if
we can okay I think Eric is not okay um
okay great so for those people who are
on our live stream we are actually about
to jump to another live stream so please
tune in we'll be there in just a couple
of moments um all right talk to you
those who are not in the next meeting
I'll talk to you soon
see you play